hero painted his room at a rate of eight
square meters per hour after three hours
of painting he had 28 square meters left
to paint so after three hours of
painting he had 28 square meters left to
pain so they're talking in terms of how
much we have left to paint not how much
we have painted let a of T denote the
area to paint a measured in square
meters as a function of time T measured
in hours so a of T once again this is
how much we have to paint not how much
we have painted right the function's
formula so what I like to do is let's
just think a couple about a couple point
here let's just make it a little bit
tangible for us so let me notice a
different color so let's think about
what a if T is at different times so
this is time this is a as a function of
time and they give us one of them they
say after three hours of painting after
three hours of painting he had 28 28
square metres left to paint and once
again a of T is how much we have left to
paint not how much we have painted so
I'm going to leave some space here for
some other valid may be 0 1 2 let's
write 3 over here after 3 hours he had
28 square meters left to paint we're
just assuming that this is going to be
in square meters and this isn't ours now
they tell us that he painted his room at
a rate of 8 square meters per hour
so let's actually back up a little bit
let's back up let's say after after 2
hours how much would he have had left to
paint how what would a ft bin would it
have been more than 28 or would have
been less than 28 well he's painting 8
square meters per hour so every hour
that goes by he's painting more but a if
T isn't how much he is painted it's how
much he has left to paint so he would
have left he would he should have less
to paint as time goes up so as time goes
up as that as time increases a of T a of
T should go down so at 2 hours he should
have more to paint than at 3 hours
because remember
is how much he has left to paint so how
much more would he have had to paint at
two hours than at three hours well it
tells us that he has eight square meters
- he paints at a rate of eight square
meters per hour so between two and three
hours he would have painted eight square
meters so at two hours he would have had
eight square meters more to paint so if
you add 8 to this right over here you
wouldn't be at 36
so you he would have had 36 square
meters to paint at 2 hours and then what
about 1 hour so in 1 hour he would have
had 8 more Square Meters to paint so 36
Plus 8 that is 44 and at 0 hours what
would he have had to paint so we just in
another color at 0 hours well he would
have had to paint 8 more square meters
so 44 plus 8 is 52 let's think about
whether that makes sense if right when
he was starting he had 52 square meters
to paint then an hour goes by so your
change in time is 1 hour and then your
change and how much he's had to have how
much he has left to paint it goes down
by 8 change in a is equal to negative 8
that makes sense his rate of change
should be negative because the amount he
has left to paint goes down as time goes
forward so this was pretty interesting
now let's see if we can actually
construct a formula or can the formula
that describes this function well this
is happening at a constant rate every
time T goes up by 1 we see a of T goes
down by 8 T goes up by 1 a if T goes
down by 8 they tell us that and that's
because he paints it at a rate of 8
square meters per hour so whenever
you're describing something that's
happening at a constant rate that can be
described by a linear function and a
linear function will have the form a of
T is equal to your rate of change times
time plus wherever you started and M and
B or just the letters that people tend
to use for your rate of change your
slope if you were graphing this and B
where you start it off and this would be
your vertical intercept is sometimes you
call it your y-intercept but in this
case would be your a intercept if we're
talking if we're thinking about the
actual it would help us find the
intercept if we were graphing this thing
but we actually already know both of
these things we know what our rate of
change is it is negative 8 I mean we
could say well what's our slope our
slope is change in change of a over
change in T change in a over let me
write it this way let me do it in a
different color just for fun so our our
let me our slope is just our change in
our dependent variable over our change
in our independent variable which is
equal to negative 8 they tell us that
it's equal to negative 8 so this thing
is equal to negative 8 and B is going to
be equal to a of 0 a of 0 well when T is
equal to 0 this term right over here
goes away and you're just left with B a
of 0 is equal to B and we know what a of
0 is it is equal to 52 so we know this
right over here is 52 and we're done
we know then I'll just rewrite it just
for fun a of T the area that they have
that he has left to paint as a function
of time is equal to negative 8 times
time times time plus 52 plus 52 and you
can confirm that the unit's make sense
because this negative 8 this negative 8
and actually out let me write it one
time with the unit's just because it is
an important thing to think about area
as a function of time this is how much
he has left to paint is going to be
equal to is going to be equal to
negative 8 negative 8 square meters per
hour so negative 8 meter squared per
hour times T hours times T hours maybe
I'll write out hours so you don't think
it's a variable T hours let me write the
hours over here T hours plus 52 square
meters plus plus let me do it right over
here plus I have trouble story switching
colors plus plus 52 square meter
and you see hours hours / hours cancels
out you just be left with meters squared
you'd have negative 80 square meters +
52 square meters and so the a of T is
going to be given to you in square
meters now there's other ways that you
might have wanted to tackle this you
might have immediately said hey look my
rate of change is 8 square meters per
hour now you have to be very careful
there you have to say what you might be
you might have said well my rate of
change maybe is going to be positive 8
square meters per hour you have to be
clear that a is not how much he's
painting it's how much he has left to
paint so his rate of change of how much
heat he has left to paint is decreasing
at 8 square meters per hour so you might
have said okay immediately this my my
formula would look like this a if T is
going to be equal to negative 8 times T
plus some B and then you could have used
this information right over here to
solve for B you say hey when T is equal
to 3 when T is equal to 3 a is equal to
28 you could have just used this
information right over here and
substitute it right over here so when T
is equal to 3 when this is 3 a of T is
28 and you have forgotten 28 is equal to
negative 8 times 3 so negative 24 plus B
and then you would have added 24 to both
sides of whoops you would have added 24
to both sides and you would have gotten
28 plus 24 is 52 52 and then on the
right side you would just have B you
would get B is equal to B is equal to 52
which is exactly what we got over there
I'd like to do it this way just to make
sure that we really conceptualize we
really grok what was going on